now the commander of Ukraine's Ground
Forces says his troops are repelling
Russian attempts to take the eastern
city of bakmut but that the situation
there is still very difficult troops
with Russia's Wagner private military
group control at least half the city but
say the fighting is becoming more
intense and that's the further that they
Advance Moscow has made a win in Bahamut
a strategic and symbolic priority
indicating they could pave the way for
further advances
in less than a week starting from March
6th we managed to kill more than 1100
enemy soldiers in the buckmut sector
alone which is Russia's irreversible
loss the loss right there near bakmots
furthermore at least 1500 more enemy
sanitary losses those who can no longer
continue fighting plus dozens of units
of enemy equipment were destroyed and
more than 10 Russian ammunition Depots
were burned down this
situation in Bahamut is tough very tough
the enemy is fighting for every meter
and the closer we are to the center of
the city the harder the fighting the
more the artillery is shelling at us the
more tanks appear the ukrainians throw
in Endless reserves but we are advancing
and we will keep advancing
with Stephanie Decker correspondent to
his following developments from Key
Force Stephanie backwood obviously is
the focus of the fighting right now I
mean conflicting reports about what's
going on in the numbers of casualties
just bring us up to speed on what we
know
it's very difficult to confirm those
numbers of dead on both sides but I
think what is very clear that it is
amounting a heavy death toll on both
sides it is an intense fight it is a
Relentless fight that's been going on
for almost uh eight months now with the
ukrainians holding the West uh the
Russians the Wagner Mercury group
holding the East now divided uh By The
mahmuta River and it's almost become
Street by street fighting hardly any
civilians are left some estimates around
four thousand of the seventy thousand
residents uh uh in the town and yes you
mentioned there it has become hugely
symbolic uh you know military analysts
will tell you that it if the Russians
take bath it will not change the course
of the war but it is a significant and
symbolic Victory you had the Russians
take the town of solidar in January
under a very similar situation after
months and months of hard fighting
um so there have been uh some gains that
the Russians have made over the last
couple of weeks and months on that
Eastern Front I mean the reality is that
the front line stretches from the north
uh to the South to Carson from kharkiv
areas being shelled but yes the focus
really has been from the politicians
from the media on the town of bakmud at
the moment but again at the moment it is
a back and forth but both sides making
it very clear that they remain
determined
um to keep digging in
for the update thanks very much
Stephanie Decker there for us in Kiev